[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend die korona pandemie hat in
ihren kennziffern heute mal einen
kleinen schritt rückwärts gemacht als
wollte sie zur pressekonferenz von
gesundheitsminister robert-koch-institut
und charité die lage verschleiern aber
keiner der fachleute mit denen wir
sprechen glaubt auch nur im geringsten
an eine entspannung im gegenteil die
lage entwickelt sich leider genauso wie
wir befürchtet hatten sagte
rki-präsident wähler es wurde höchste
zeit gegenmaßnahmen hochzufahren und da
zeigen die bundesländer erneut ein
widersprüchliches bild und die fürs
erste dringend der aktion die dritte
impfung für besonders gefährdete geht
nur stotternd voran dominik müller sl
über den stand der dinge
im seniorenheim park residence in neuss
bei düsseldorf rollte die dritte im
fälle hausärztin martina von schreiter
erklärt bewohner in hanna wendt den sinn
und nutzen
hanna wendt will sich auffrischen lassen
sie ist 87 ihre immunabwehr schwach
vertrauen in den ärztlichen rat auch bei
den pflegekräften die sind bei ihnen im
haus alle geimpft einen impf durchbruch
gab es hier glücklicherweise noch nicht
bislang großer angst ist natürlich wir
haben und großteil unserer patienten ist
weit über die 80 jahre das heißt als
wärme vom alter her ein recht altes
klientel und haben da schon unsere sorge
dass es jetzt doch noch mal jemanden
erwischen können von daher halte ich das
schon für eine wichtige sache dass diese
dritte impfung auch laufen muss sechs
millionen menschen könnten schon gebucht
seien zwei millionen sind es erst die
kampagne nimmt nur langsam fahrt auf und
gleichzeitig sind mehr als 16 millionen
menschen über zwölf jahren noch kein
einziges mal geimpft ok-chef wieder gibt
heute einen düsteren ausblick
für ungeimpfte ist das risiko hoch dass
sie sich in den nächsten monaten
infizieren dass einige von ihnen schwer
krank werden und auch dass sie andere
anstecken wenn wir jetzt nicht
gegensteuern wie diese vierte welle
wieder viel leid bringen es werden viele
menschen schwer erkranken und sterben
und das gesundheitswesen wird wieder
stark belastet vor allem in pflegeheimen
gilt es unbedingt ins durchbrüche zu
verhindern von einer gesetzlichen
impfpflicht für pflegepersonal hält der
bundesgesundheitsminister allerdings
nichts bekräftigte er heute stattdessen
soll mehr und schneller gemustert werden
darauf habe man sich bereits im august
verständigt das ist jetzt drei monate
her und in diesen drei monaten hat es
bis heute nur gut zwei millionen
auffrischimpfungen in deutschland
gegeben das ist zu wenig es ist deutlich
zu wenig das möchte ich auch klipp und
klar sagen das tempo beim boostern
reicht nicht die ärzteschaft wird sich
vielmehr führten die widersprüchlichen
booster empfehlungen des
gesundheitsministers und der stiko zur
verunsicherung ob ab 70 oder 60 oder für
alle und auch die bürokratischen
prozesse verlangsamten viel wir haben
die patienten bei der ersten impfung
aufgeklärt und aufklärung und
einwilligung unterschreiben lassen wir
haben es bei der zweiten impfung gemacht
alle sind überrascht wie jetzt bei der
dritten auch nochmal wir müssen es
unterschreiben die patienten müssen sie
unterschreiben die bürokratie die
brauchen wir nicht diskussionen uns
nicht die boostern und andere sind noch
kein einziges mal geimpft die sagt
hausärztin von schreiter müssen nun
unbedingt erreicht werden
wie sollen menschen daran glauben dass
impfung sich nicht nur lohnt sondern
über leben und tod entscheiden kann wenn
meldungen kommen dass es in alters und
pflegeheimen zu impft durchbrüchen kommt
zu fällen also in denen das virus den
impfschutz überwältigt und wenn sich
dann noch herausstellt dass selbst
pflegepersonal das täglich mit der
krankheit zu tun hat sich selbst nicht
impfen lässt wie es jetzt bei den
tragischen ausbrüchen mit vielen toten
in brandenburg mecklenburg und schleswig
holstein waren christine vogler hat
große praktische berufserfahrung in der
pflege und ist die präsidentin des
deutschen pflegerates guten abend einen
schönen guten abend herr kleber frau
vogler warum lassen sich denn nicht alle
in der pflege impfen die müssten es doch
wissen
ja das ist eine spannende frage aber ist
sie haben es ja gerade angesprochen dass
gerade die situation in den pflegeheimen
jetzt nach vorne geholt wird und gesagt
wird die pflegenden lassen sich nicht im
wir haben keine validen zahlen
wir können nur sagen die pflegenden mit
denen wir zu tun haben die tragen dem
berufsethos in sich die menschen zu
schützen die sie versorgen und die
zahlen sind hier werden hier sehr
differenziert dargestellt in in den
heimen in den kliniken arbeiten viele
menschen der arbeit nicht nur
pflegefachpersonen sondern auch viele
andere menschen und wir müssen einfach
ganz genau hinschauen wie kommen diese
durchbrüche zustande wie kommen die
infektionswege zustande um hier wirklich
auch gut da gegensteuern zu können und
ich glaube was wir vermeiden müssen ist
jetzt nachdem die pflegenden seit gut
anderthalb jahren die fahne hochhalten
und die menschen versorgen jetzt diese
ins visier zu nehmen und gefühlt nach
schuldigen zu suchen die an ausbrüchen
tatsächlich schuld sein das ist glaube
ich der falsche weg momentan damit
umzugehen da kann man ihnen sicher nur
zustimmen trotzdem kann ich sie aus
dieser frage noch nicht entlassen denn
in den fällen in brandenburg
schleswig-holstein niedersachsen
ist geklärt dass viele im pflegepersonal
nicht geimpft waren und auch wenn man
wie wir journalisten immer wieder
solchen sachen hinterher
recherchieren dann stellt sich doch aus
dass in vielen häusern die leitung des
hauses probleme hat über eine impfquote
von 70 80 prozent hinaus zu kommen
manche erreichen 100 ja aber natürlich
verunsichert das natürlich auch viele
patienten wenn die sagen meine
krankenschwester und übrigens auch der
eine oder andere arzt sagen mir auch ich
weiß nicht also ich lasse es mal lieber
die nebenwirkung ich weiß nicht und
damit sind menschen natürlich sehr
verunsichert und da kommt eine
zusätzliche pflicht der quasi auf das
pflegepersonal zu das sind wir sind
jetzt seit gut anderthalb jahren in der
panini sie hört nicht auf und was wir
stark vermissen ist eine
zielgruppengerechte prävention wir haben
die bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung wo sind die auf wo sind die
videos die wir auf facebook sehen
könnten auf twitter wo sind sie zum
beispiel geschaltet vor den zdf vom zdf
heute journal die zwei minuten wo sind
die plakate im straßenbild wo sind die
flyer die für aufklärung sorgen die
punkt aktuell auch die neuigkeiten
bringen also was haben wir geschafft in
den anderthalb jahren an aufklärungs
formaten zu transportieren auch
zielgerichtet und ich meine die
pflegenden wir sind 1,2 millionen fach
pflegende in deutschland selbst wenn da
ein prozent sagt wir wollen uns nicht
impfen lassen ist dass eine hohe zahl
und wir müssen einfach schauen dass wir
die menschen überzeugen und abholen und
nachfragen wenn sie sagen ich habe sorge
mich impfen zu lassen die nicht zu
verurteilen und zu sagen das ist jetzt
eine dumme aussage sondern zu sagen okay
was ist die sorge und dann eben hier
ganz gezielte aufklärung zu machen und
arbeitgeber für die heime und auch für
die kliniken können sicherlich an der
stelle auch noch vielleicht ein bisschen
aufklärungsarbeit unterstützen wenn das
pflegepersonal im moment merkt und auch
hört was der präsident des rki heute
gesagt hat dass die unter
gesundheitsminister dass diese vierte
welle noch mal richtig schlimm werden
dann kann dann kommt das ja auf die auch
zu was sagen sie ich habe das gehört was
sie sagten über aufklärungsaktionen was
müsste sich in der praxis im moment aus
ihrer sicht noch ändern und mit dieser
vierten welle fertig zu werden
in der praxis wird wir können die welle
schier nicht aufhalten also was
pflegende und was die menschen in die
gesundheitsberufen tun ist die menschen
die sie versorgen die pflegebedürftigen
die patientinnen und patienten wirklich
tatsächlich zu schützen die pflegenden
sind ja selbst betroffen durch
ungeimpfte oder durch menschen die den
virus tragen die seit anderthalb jahren
seit zwei jahren schützen wir uns ja
130000 pflegen sind weltweit bereits
verstorben unter dem unter dem virus
also ich denke aber gerade darunter
warum wehrt sich die branche immer noch
gegen eine impfpflicht zumindest für
dieses wichtige personal die impfpflicht
ist der falsche weg ich glaube wirklich
zwang an der stelle erzeugt viel höhere
widerstände ich glaube wir müssen in
einer demokratischen gesellschaft
brauchen wir den discos mit den menschen
und wir müssen nach wie vor versuchen
und ich glaube wirklich präventiv zu
arbeiten
das haben wir noch lange nicht
ausgeschöpft und aufklärungsarbeit zu
machen auch nicht wir müssen jetzt noch
mal nachlegen und zwar schnell der rat
der präsidentin des deutschen
pflegerates dankeschön frau vogler und
an guten abend in st
wir nehmen uns als redaktion immer
wieder vor über den problemen zu hause
den rest der welt nicht zu vergessen in
denen sich überlagernden schatten von
pandemie klimawandel und dem
heraufziehenden kalten krieg zwischen
dem westen und china eskaliert die
tragödie eines der faszinierendsten
länder afrikas eine fast seit jesu
zeiten christliche nation bis heute
stolz darauf niemals als kolonie von
europa geknechtet worden zu sein
äthiopien präsident ahmed bekam vor zwei
jahren den friedensnobelpreis weil er
einen blutigen konflikt beendete
politische gefangene befreite und
demokratie versprach dass wurde eine
katastrophale enttäuschung im krieg
gegen die abtrünnige nordprovinz t3
steht er der rebellen armee nicht nach
in menschenverachtung und brutalität
susan von lojewski berichtet aus süd ost
afrika
es ist noch nicht lange her da feierte
die welt den äthiopischen premier ahmed
2009/10 bekam der mann aus afrika den
friedensnobelpreis für seine ausbildung
mit dem verfeindeten eritrea war das ein
fehler seit wochen fliegen us truppen
luftangriffe auf die nordprovinz tigra
äthiopien spricht von militärischen
zielen t3 dagegen von lokalen gebäuden
und zivilen opfern explosionen ohne tote
gehören inzwischen zum alltag der
konflikt sei von extremer brutalität
geprägt das jedenfalls erzählt der
bericht der un hochkommissarin zur
menschenrechtslage in der region
äthiopien unterstützt vom einstigen
erzfeind eritrea aber habe die
hauptverantwortung
sie die zivilbevölkerung ist brutaler
gewalt und leid ausgesetzt unser
untersuchungsteam hat zahlreiche
gewalttaten und misshandlungen aus
gedeckt mit rechtswidrigen tötungen und
exekutionen folter sexueller und
geschlechtsspezifischer gewalt
die tische befreiungsfront tplf
rekrutiert unterdessen immer mehr
kämpfer auch sie haben ihren anteil
hinterlassen blutige spuren der konflikt
weitet sich beinahe täglich aus in addis
adeba rief premierminister ahmed gestern
den landesweiten ausnahmezustand aus
schwor die bevölkerung auf einen harten
kampf ein
diese grube livia sehr tief ausheben
werden wird der ort sein an dem unser
feind begraben wird nicht der ort an dem
äthiopien zerfällt wir werden diesen
feind mit unserem blut und unseren
knochen begraben und in rom äthiopiens
wieder hochleben lassen
martialische worte eines
friedensnobelpreisträgers der
gleichzeitig alle männer aufrief zu den
waffen zu greifen
nicht wenige halten seine auszeichnung
inzwischen für einen großen fehler
vielleicht zählt der preis normalerweise
darauf ab akteure zu inspirieren oder zu
ermutigen positiver zu handeln das hat
sich nicht immer bewahrheitet wie wir
jetzt sehen die fronten sind inzwischen
so verhärtet dass selbst die konvois das
weltende das programm ist nicht mehr
durchkommen experten fürchten einen
flächenbrand
bekommt mit der konflikt wird sich auf
die gesamte region am horn von afrika
und sogar auf den kampf gegen die
terroristische bedrohung sowohl in
somalia als auch in der regierung aus
hunderttausende sind bereits auf der
flucht in die nachbarländer 5 millionen
menschen von akuter unterernährung
bedroht und das blutvergießen geht
weiter
und nachrichten nun von gundula gause us
präsident biden und seine demokratische
partei haben bei den gouverneurswahlen
im bundesstaat virginia einen rückschlag
erfahren der republikaner yang qin
setzte sich knapp im bislang
demokratisch regierten virginia durch
seinen rivalen kolles nützte die
unterstützung von joe biden nicht bei
der kongresswahl im kommenden jahr steht
nun die hauchdünne mehrheit der
demokraten auf dem spiel einen erfolg
konnten die demokraten allerdings in new
york verbuchen dort setzte sich ihr
kandidat der frühere polizist eric adams
durch
die spd will am kommenden montag das
vorgehen bei der nachfolge von noch
parteichef norbert walter borjans klären
aus der spd heißt es bis dahin werde
auch co chefin saskia esken entscheiden
ob sie erneut antrete als kandidat für
die nachfolge von walter borjans wird
der bisherige generalsekretär gehandelt
lars klingbeil es ehre ihn dass sein
name genannt werde so äußerte er sich in
führungsgremien der spd
rund zehn jahre nach bekanntwerden des
rechtsextremen terrornetzwerks nsu haben
politiker und zivile organisationen
fehlende konsequenzen aus dem fall
kritisiert amnesty international
forderte mehr einsatz im kampf gegen
menschenfeindliche gewalt am vierten
november 2011 war das rechtsextreme
netzwerk nach einem banküberfall in
eisenach aufgeflogen zwischen 2000 und
2007 hatten die mitglieder des
sogenannten nsu insgesamt zehn menschen
ermordet die meisten hatten einen
migrationshintergrund
der tod eines flüchtlings aus sierra
leone in einer polizeizelle in dessau
ist auch fast 17 jahre später nicht
geklärt die initiative in gedenken an
oury jalloh hat jetzt ein neues
brandgutachten vorgestellt mit dem sie
belegen will dass der mann in seiner
zelle gefesselt angezündet worden sei
sonderermittlungen und zwei prozesse
konnten den fall bislang nicht klären
umfassende aufarbeitung hatten in
sachsen anhalt kürzlich
217.000 menschen in einer petition
gefordert
im osten des pazifiks soll ein riesiges
meeresschutzgebiet entstehen das haben
die präsidenten von ecuador kolumbien
costa rica und panama beim
un-klimagipfel in glasgow angekündigt es
soll die kolumbianische insel mal pelo
mit den galapagos-inseln vor ecuador und
weiteren inseln von costa rica und
panama verbinden in dem rund 500.000
quadratkilometer großen gebiet leben
hunderte meeres tier und vogelarten
schildkröten und hammerhaie sollen dort
geschützt und industrieller fischfang
verboten werden und
kann so was machen konferenz beschlüsse
bürgerinitiativen und
regierungsprogramme sind das eine
knallharte fakten sind das machtvolle
und da sind geld und gewinn die
mächtigsten hebel der klimawandel wird
unsere welt verändern und das heißt auch
investitionen die heute noch profitabel
scheinen sind es bald nicht mehr
ressourcen werden knapp konsumenten
werden manche dinge nicht mehr haben
wollen lieferketten werden gestört
meeresspiegel steigen diese gedanken
setzen sich zunehmend auch in der
finanzwelt durch langsam noch ziemlich
langsam verlagern sich investitionen in
richtung einer grünen zukunft
wer an börsen und anderen quellen geld
abzapfen will der muss seine ideen und
sein produkt auch als grün verkaufen
können diana zimmermann richtet
kunst auszahlen die überschwappende
farb- wellen sind aus daten errechnet
die szenarien des klimawandels
entsprechen sollen es ist eines der
projekte mit hilfe derer carlos sanchez
versucht erahnbar zu machen was uns
bevorsteht und warum nun gehandelt
werden muss früher hatten wir landkarten
die uns erschrecken jetzt gibt es
wirklich gute daten aus denen man sogar
angst machen kann am ende müssen
lösungen stehen
sanchez berät unternehmen darin den
klimawandel in ihren investitionen zu
berücksichtigen und zeigt auf was sie
tun können um ihn aufzuhalten das geld
so resümiert er fließt endlich in die
richtige richtung green finance ist
eines der großen themen auf der
un-klimakonferenz heute zog
finanzminister kees vlak für britische
finanzinstitutionen und börsennotierte
unternehmen die zügel an
wir werden es verpflichtend machen dass
firmen klare und realistische pläne
vorlegen in denen sie darstellen wie sie
den übergang zur klimaneutralität
schaffen
auch freiwillig haben unternehmen
natürlich längst begonnen klimabewusst
zu investieren lange stieg das grüne
wachstum jährlich um 25 prozent doch
schon vor der korona krise schwächte
sich ab und die bisher 632 milliarden
dollar pro jahr erreichen bei weitem
nicht um bis 2050 klimaneutralität zu
erreichen müsste es rund sechsmal soviel
seien die
investoren einfach ein
ein sicheres umwelt umfeld sehen das
durch anreize geschaffen werden kann
da gehen sie in diesem bereich und das
ist etwas wo man sicher gehen muss dass
es nicht weiterhin subventionen gibt für
sozusagen die die fossilen energieträger
genau das ist das problem an appellen
mangelt ist auf der kop nicht und doch
investieren amerikaner und briten weiter
heftig in gas und öl wird in deutschland
weiter braunkohle gefördert
greenwashing nur so zu tun als
wirtschafter man grün werfen
umweltaktivisten politik und wirtschaft
vor schon ökonomisch aber macht das auf
dauer keinen sinn davon ist sanchez fest
überzeugt
die jetzt schon vorangehen werden davon
profitieren wenn das system sich ändert
und ändern wird es sich sie werden
konkurrenzfähig fortschrittlich und
innovativ dastehen wenn wir jetzt diese
gelegenheit verpassen und es nicht
schaffen die investitionen im nötigen
ausmaß auszudehnen dann können wir nur
noch verluste minimieren und das wird
einen menschlicher eine wirtschaftliche
und eine ökologische katastrophe führen
im moment
ohne geld kein klimaschutz das ist schon
heute allen klar wenn sich die einsicht
durchsetzt dass es ohne klimaschutz kein
geld gibt könnte das mehr bewegen als so
manches versprechen der politik
und passend dazu kam heute die meldung
aus nordrhein-westfalen dass dort der
neue ministerpräsident wüst erklärte
sein land sei bereit für einen
kohleausstieg schon 2030 geplant ist
jahr 2038 die politik schafft also
rahmenbedingungen für die wirtschaft
frank bethmann die nun globale standards
der nachhaltigkeit einhalten soll so
beschlossen glasgow mit auswirkungen in
frankfurt ja ganz genau heute fiel die
entscheidung frankfurt wird hauptsitz
einer neu geschaffenen institutionen die
die wichtige aufgabe bekommt überhaupt
erst mal weltweit gültige nachhaltigkeit
normen zu entwickeln bislang gibt es die
so nämlich gar nicht das soll der ssb
der international sustainability den
export nun ändern er soll konkret
weltweite standards für die klima
bezogene finanzberichterstattung von
unternehmen festlegen gleich mehrere
metropolen haben um das
prestigeträchtige gremium geworden für
frankfurt sprachen dass es hier nur über
das es hier über 200 banken gibt und
natürlich auch weitere internationale
organisation und warum sind denn gerade
diese internationalen standards in der
finanzberichterstattung so wichtig na ja
wir haben ja bereits gehört geld muss
jetzt ganz schnell viel schneller als
bisher grün werden damit das passiert
müssen die investoren hier an der börse
aber beurteilen können welches
geschäftsmodell ist denn überhaupt
wirklich nachhaltig und welches nicht
und genau dafür benötigt man diese
transparente und vor allem überall
gleiche berichterstattung fakt ist
nämlich dass das weltweit derzeit noch
ein ziemlicher flickenteppich ist und
damit sind derzeit dem green washing
also dem etikettenschwindel tür und tor
geöffnet anleger nicht nur mit großen
auch die mit kleinerem portemonnaie aber
wollen genau wissen fließt er nun mein
geld wirklich in die richtigen projekte
und dafür ist diese internationale
vergleichbarkeit ein ganz wichtiger
baustein
danke für die einordnung von pierer
bundeskanzlerin merkel verabschiedet
sich zur stunde mit einem besonderen
besuch von frankreichs premier makro
nicht wie üblich in paris sondern im
weinort wohnen im burgund offiziell
stehen neben aktuellen internationalen
themen auch ein klavierkonzert auf dem
programm sowie ein privates abendessen
im anschluss erhält jetzt gerade seine
freundin wie makro merkel nennt
frankreichs höchste auszeichnung das
gros kreuz der ehrenlegion
eine meldung vom tennis beim atp masters
turnier in paris hat dominik koepfer aus
furtwangen das nächste schwergewicht
besiegt erst andy murray und jetzt den
kanadier felix oder alias weltranglisten
elften damit steht köpfer die nummer 58
der welt im achtelfinale viele noch die
gewinnzahlen vom lotto am mittwoch sie
lauten ohne gewähr 10 13 14
28 44 49 superzahl weitere gewinnzahlen
auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
heute vor 20 jahren ist thomas brasch
gestorben im alter von 56 prall
gefüllten jahren seine familie die
branche schreibt der film redakteur der
welt waren für die ddr was die familie
mann für den westen wurde ein geflecht
faszinierender talentierter menschen
eher thomas allerdings sein leben lang
mit der neun jahre jüngeren katharina
thalbach verbunden branche vater später
ein jüdischer antifaschist war den nazis
1939 in einem dieser kindertransporte
nach england entkommen wurde einer der
überzeugten sozialisten die nach dem
krieg zurückkamen um die ddr aufzubauen
er brachte es dort zum vize
kulturminister
sein sohn thomas wurde und blieb ein
romantiker regisseur autor und system
sprenger er und die real existierende
ddr vertrugen sich nicht er reiste aus
und die ddr war froh ihn los zu sein so
ein leben ist ein film andreas kleinert
traute sich ihn zu machen nadia nasa hat
ihnen vor der premiere heute abend
gesehen sie feiern heute abend einen der
auszug unruhe zu stiften roter teppich
in berlin premiere der filmbiographie
über thomas brasch gespielt von albrecht
schuch eine lebensgeschichte zwischen
ost und west erzielt in traumhaft
schönen schwarz weiß bildern die ich
kenne will ich nicht mehr sehen aber wo
ich lebe da will ich nicht sterben aber
wo ich sterbe da will ich nicht hin
ein zerrissener mensch rebellisch
widersprüchlich und nie regelkonform
schon als student eckte an
ich bin hier die dozenten nicht an
andere ressorts von gesang und fliegt
von der hochschule branche will
schreiben die welt verbessern ein
ausnahmetalent ein lebemann und
provokateur wenn wir hier behandelt
werden die gefangenen dann soll sich die
genossen auch nicht wundern wenn wir uns
ab sofort auch dementsprechend verhalten
dass er immer eingefordert hat dass man
dinge differenziert betrachten muss
vielschichtig und nicht schnell
abhandeln kann dass man sich streiten
muss es gibt regeln dabei kommt er aus
strengen sozialistischem haushalt vater
horst ist hoher sed parteifunktionär die
vater-sohn-beziehung
konfliktgeladene
mit freunden verteilt er 1968
flugblätter protest gegen die
niederschlagung des prager frühlings die
aktion fliegt auf thomas flieht in die
elterliche wohnung wird dort aber
aufgespürt und verhaftet
der film folgt der version die branche
sein leben lang erzählte er wurde
verraten vom eigenen vater brasch muss
für einige monate ins gefängnis in der
ddr ist für ihn kein raum mehr seine
stücke werden verboten
1976 geht er mit seiner damaligen
freundin katharina thalbach gespielt von
jella haase und deren tochter nach west
berlin aber auch hier kann er nicht
richtig fuß fassen
für bosch war es glaube ich schlimm dass
er die idee also wenig präsent war das
hat ihn natürlich total belastet wenn
man arbeitet und keine das lesen und
sehen und das war sicherlich auch ein
hauptgrund warum wir dann später
gegangen ist und aber er ist eben nicht
mit der erwartung gang jetzt kommt das
tolle jetzt kommt das flyer sondern erst
von dem einen verrotteten system in das
system der echte thomas brasch mit
lebensgefährtin katharina thalbach im
westen er feiert einige erfolge als
autor und regisseur zeigt zwei filme in
cannes aber er verweigert sich auch will
seine haut nicht zu markte tragen sie
fühlen sich von uns ausgebildet sie sind
der
kellner
die fernsehzuschauer sind die gäste und
ich bin ein schnitzel das woran ja am
meisten gescheitert ist es er selbst
gewesen auch weil er hatte natürlich
visionen und utopien und die haben sich
so nicht eingelöst schlagt mich doch aus
ich bin doch keine ware
lieber thomas ein tief bewegender film
über einen der nirgendwo reinpasst ewig
zweifelt und sehnsüchtig
der satz mit dem schnitzel der geht
einem nicht schnell aus dem kopf der
film ist im kino ab dem 11 november im
anschluss jetzt das auslandsjournal die
doku auf den spuren der umwelt mafia die
autoren zeigen wie kriminelle netzwerke
unseren planeten plündern und die natur
zerstört und 0 45 ist hier wieder zeit
für unser heute-journal update mit nazan
gattin ihren einen schönen abend noch
bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend zwischen dem tief peter und
dem hoch sylvie ziehen die regenwolken
hier über dem atlantik nach süden und
stauen sich am kantabrischen gebirge
kommen da also nicht weiter voran
deswegen regnet es dort kräftig auch bei
uns fällt viel regen und zwar mit dem
tief peter das schauen wir uns jetzt
noch einmal genauer an denn dieses tief
peter bringt schnee auch bei uns in
deutschland jedenfalls oberhalb von 800
meter im schwarzwald oder auch an den
alpen und morgens sieht dieses tief
weiter nach nordosten reicht bis morgen
abend bereits polen und es wird kräftig
diesen besonders im nordosten
deutschlands heute nacht gibt es vor
allen dingen zwischen den mittelgebirgen
und am alpenrand fällt wie gesagt schon
schnee oberhalb von 800 metern im norden
das ist zum teil trocken es bildet sich
auch mal nebel und es sinken die
temperaturen auf zwei grad die rund um
münster oder osnabrück oder auch am
alpenrand sonst bleibt die nacht bei 7
bis 4 grad milder und morgen liegen die
temperaturen zwischen 5 grad am
alpenrand und maximal 10 grad zum
beispiel an der ostsee oder auch in der
lausitz und an der nordsee das wird ein
sehr verregneter donnerstag dann
heftigsten schützen wird es vom
erzgebirge bis zur ostsee am vortag
bereits lockern die wolken hier am
alpenrand schon ein bisschen auf der
hörte es auf zu regnen und zwischen dem
sauerland und nordfriesland regnet es
auch nicht insgesamt kommen im westen
durchaus 5 liter regen pro quadratmeter
zusammen im süden sind es 15 und hier im
osten über 40 quadratmeter in den
nächsten tagen beruhigt sich das wetter
gesehen häufiger die sonne und die
temperaturen steigen auf 5 bis 12 grad
gute nacht